you and I left a good life behind a long
time ago my friend
the gun and the gold coins which we're
gonna tell you what to watch this week
for free 99 and that's a weekly special
along with John Wick chapter 4 we got
new seasons for two of the most
anticipated shows of the year one new
series that has great expectations going
in and the first of many special
anniversary wrecks all tied to a special
someone's 25th birthday don't worry we
know you remembered as always we got
everything you'll need to survive the
coming week on this episode of what to
watch challenge into single combat if
you win you will have your freedom
amen if thought the John Wick franchise
was running out of bullets and may just
have brought out its biggest guns yet
guys critic response isn't just good
with a hundred reviews John Wick chapter
4 is at a certified fresh 94 which is
rare for Action films and even rarer for
fourth outings but the praise doesn't
stop there many critics don't just think
it's the best John Wick of them all it
makes a case for Action aficionados to
place it on their best of all time lists
don't take it from me check out the RT
website and read the critic quotes
yourself according to the critics not
only does the action continue to
astonish and Dazzle but this time around
it manages to weave in a thoughtful
story amongst its incredible new set of
characters which includes action Legends
Donnie Yen hiroyuki Sonata and Scott
Adkins with additional praise to
newcomer Japanese and British music star
Ria sawayama making her film debut
lastly this will mark one of the final
films of late actor Lance Riddick who
played every hitman's favorite Class Act
concierge Karen from all of us at Ron
tomato knows thank you for all the joy
you brought and rest in peace you point
your finger at me I point my finger at
you we are gonna grind you down man we
are sanding the gears I hate you do you
understand that loud and clear good done
arriving in the boardroom for its final
season is the hit HBO show succession
speaking of strong succession with every
single season certified fresh including
season four currently at a hundred
percent and two Emmy wins for
Outstanding Drama Series and three for
outstanding writing it's no surprise
series Creator Jesse Armstrong reserved
marking season 4 as the grand finale
until recent but I think you'll like his
reasons stating in an interview with the
New Yorker we could do a couple of short
Seasons or two more seasons or we could
do something a bit more muscular and
complete and go out strong and that was
definitely always my preference
succession fans will already know the
biggest reason to tune in but if it
isn't obvious the big question still
looms who will succeed in running way
star royco will it be one of the
children in the dysfunctional Roy family
one of the dysfunctional Roy board
members or perhaps another dysfunctional
entity entirely whatever the case we can
expect something surprising coming from
L to the LG cause dude beta-o-g there's
some
how their moment let us step outside I
thought we left it there and we were
rescued
but now I realize
getting the team back together for a
second season is the series
Yellowjackets aka the main reason all
your friends have Showtime season two is
currently certified fresh at a hundred
percent with 22 reviews matching season
1 score making the series an absolute
critical darling thus far with a critics
consensus stating having already made a
startling first impression Yellowjackets
coils itself in a second season
preparing for the Long Haul thankfully
its superb performances and Miss Merrick
Ambience are fine substitutes for fast
answers Yellowjackets was also nominated
for six Emmys for its first season with
stars like Melanie Linsky and Christina
Ricci stealing the show and now season 2
promises a few new faces including
Lauren Ambrose and Simone Castle as
adult versions of van and Lottie plus
more shocking survivalry as winter
arrives in the woods you really want to
win Australia you will need more than
love
I tell you to do and coming to FX on
Hulu is the series Great Expectations
based of course on the classic Charles
Dickens novel of the same name among the
reasons to check out this famous story
which is a Timeless critique of the
class system is that it will be told
with the help of fion Whitehead best
known as the lead role in Dunkirk and
Olivia Coleman who has an Emmy and an
Oscar in her trophy case plus the period
drama was developed by Stephen Knight
the creator of peaky blinders okay hold
the singing and send your gifts in the
mail for we have a special wreck this
week courtesy of round Tomato's 25th
anniversary we're celebrating 25
incredible years of serving you the
freshest picks that movies and TV had to
offer expect to see a special
anniversary pick every once in a while
on what to watch highlighting other
anniversaries of Classic Entertainment
on the big and small screen and we're
starting right now with we parted Hook
Line and Sinker now they get away with
eight million dollars of Sandra Van
Ryan's money you want makeup there's
more to this story you know the 25th
anniversary of the Christian musical
wild things this is one of those if you
know you know far from being Christian
or a musical this 1998 neo-noir crime
Thriller Stars Denise Richards Kevin
Bacon Matt Dillon and if you missed her
being absent in Scream 6 the scream
Queen Legend nav Campbell aside from
being well known for its wild and steamy
scenes setting Ablaze the imaginations
of countless young Millennials the movie
was critically praised for also being a
smartly written Thriller with a twisted
plot Legend Roger Ebert who gave the
film three out of four stars said this
about the film it was like a three-way
collision between a sophore sex film a
soap opera and a b grade Noir I liked it
so did we so did we Roger it was even
nominated for an award the MTV movie
award for best kiss of course but it
strangely lost to Shakespearean love
that's a loss we'll never get over there
you have it our very Dynamic list of
what to watch this week let us know
which ones you plan to catch but also
help others out in the comments if we
happen to miss some remember to check
out rottentomatoes.com for the latest
updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large and of
course check out the new rt25 page where
we'll be celebrating 25 years of rotten
tomatoes with articles dedicated to our
history best of lists and hey look at
that our brand new card game putting
your cinephile mind to the test on 25
years of Tomato Meter scores well that's
all for today fresh family until next
week stay fresh
[Music]
foreign